oh so this is the third of the Frankie
lectures this year which I held
which the semester is somehow us being
in time and I am absolutely delighted to
welcome Robert Brandon to us here at
Yale Brandon as I'm sure many of you
know is arguably one of the leading
philosophers in the world and he has
been selected to present to give many of
the most prestigious international
lecture series including the John Locke
lectures in 2006
he's currently professor of philosophy
at the University of Pittsburgh and he
works across a wide range of fields and
philosophy ranging from frost field
language philosophy of mind gloss field
logic to German idealism and
neopragmatism so among his many books
the monumental making it explicit from
1994 is usually considered to be his
most important work along with between
staying and doing it towards an analytic
pragmatism I also want to make a case
though for tales of the mighty dead not
just because it's a great great title
but because it's a great example of
randoms unique ability to combine doing
systemic philosophy in its own right
with really contributing to
understanding of the history of
philosophy so in a also the mighty dad
the mighty dad include the cart Spinoza
Leibnitz count Hegel Freya Heidegger and
sellers who are given great treatment in
their own right but also contribute to
further random zone fraud yeah that's
just a little sample of its part I want
to quote one thing that I always quote
to my students and I think bandwidth
giving the best definition of the
difference between dualistic and
dialectical thinking so Branham says
that like a distinction becomes a
dualism when you can no longer explain
the relation between the terms
distinguished no then you've got them
stuck in dualism whereas if you're doing
dialectics you'll be able to distinguish
the terms while still accounting for
their relation and Counting for their
inseparability and Brennan was really a
master at doing that in his work since
I'm sure his work can seem daunting to a
lot of people in northern professional
philosophy I also want to just end with
two recommendations where to begin
the first is to read the first chapter
making explicit which is just
extraordinarily lucid and also like when
I read that the first time I realized
like all of these discussions of
normativity in the last couple of
decades I realize like oh this is the
crystalline source of all of these
discussions they're like going there
we're like you will be able to orient
yourself in that contemporary debate
much much better
and the second tips I want to give is
the great book of Hegel's phenomenology
that's coming out in May is spirits of
trust like many others I've been reading
versions of that online for many years
but finally we're gonna get a bound copy
that clocks in at a modest eight hundred
pages
yeah and it's a preview from that book
that we'll have the pleasure of hearing
tonight so please join me in welcoming
Rob fandom to Yale he should really say
welcoming me back to Yale I was
undergraduate here and that's a very
special place to me
Hegel thinks that the most important
event in human history simply the single
biggest thing that ever happened to us
is the extended transition from
long-standing traditional forms of life
to distinctively modern ones and he
introduces and develops an original
conception of the subject of this great
sea change what he calls Geist spirit
Geist is us as discursive beings knowers
and doers and it includes all our norm
governed doings
thinking's sayings practices and
institutions and all of their products
prelapsarian traditional understanding
took normative statuses to be features
of the objective world how its proper to
behave how things ought to be done what
things are fitting proper relations of
subordination and superiority are all
thought of as central features of how
things anyway are like the weight of
stones for the color of the sky people
stations and their corresponding duties
are construed as being what they are
antecedently to and independently of the
practical attitudes of those who
stations and duties they are it's the
job of individual subjects to reflect
those self standing normative statuses
in their attitudes to shape their
acknowledgments and attributions of
authority and responsibility so that
they fit the preexisting normative facts
the principle defining traditional what
Hegel calls Italy forms of Geist is
commitment to the norm governess or
status dependence of normative attitudes
the contrasting core modern idea
articulated and developed to begin with
by Enlightenment thinkers is that there
were no normative statuses for instance
of subordination and superiority no
authority and responsibility until
people started practically taking or
treating each other as subordinates and
superiors authoritative and responsible
that modern idea is the idea of the
attitude dependence of normative
statuses this idea takes a particularly
clear and explicit form
in social contract theories of political
obligation for their attitudes of
consent by the governed are treated as
essential to the legitimate authority of
those who govern epitomized in the model
of instituting normative statuses of
reciprocal obligation by attitudes of
intending to be bound manifested
practically by entering into an explicit
contract or compact on this model norms
are not found but made normative
statuses are instituted by social
normative practical attitudes such as
promising agreeing or contracting Hegel
both sees the replacement of traditional
thought institutions themselves by
modern ones as a decisive irrevocable
advance and also diagnoses it as a
disruption that inevitably incurs
substantial costs the cover term he
coins to characterize that unavoidable
loss is alienation and friend ohm
although it has psychological
consequences alienation is not at base a
psychological phenomenon it's a
distinctively meta physical structure of
normativity itself it's a structure
characterized by the absence of the
binding nests of norms a structure in
which attitudes are no longer answerable
to or responsible to norms the largest
philosophical lesson Hegel thinks we can
learn from thinking about the great
structural shift of Geist from its
pre-modern to its modern form is the
result of the detailed interplay of gain
and loss advance and retreat that
characterized that transition the right
understanding of how those interwoven
strands are related points the way he
thinks toward the third stage and the
development of Christ such a third
structure of Geist must retain the
irreversible progress in
self-consciousness of ourselves as free
that consists in realizing the attitude
dependence of normative statuses while
reaching practical zitnick appreciation
of the status dependence of normative
attitudes the way in which normative
attitudes are obliged to respect and
reflect norms that service standards of
assessment for the correctness of those
zip the kite is practically appreciating
and responding to the obligation to
conform our attitudes to the actual
normative statuses those attitudes
acknowledge and attribute this is to aim
at acknowledging and attributing what we
and others are really committed to our
actual responsibilities and it's the
loss of this practical appreciation of
the status dependence of normative
attitudes that Hegel denominates the
alienation that he takes to be a
hallmark of modernity what we really
needed from is the norms that we have
made and that make us what we are so
there's a tension between the claim
central to modernity that normative
statuses are instituted by normative
attitudes and the claim central to
traditional understanding that normative
statuses provide the standards for
assessment of the correctness of
attitudes how can we both make the norms
and be genuinely governed by them here
one might think of it constrains
observation that if whatever is going to
seem right to me is right that only
means that here we can't talk about
right the third postmodern stage of
Geist is defined by its reconciliation
of those opposed insights how does Hegel
propose that these two criteria of
adequacy on an account of the relations
between normative attitudes and
normative statuses can be satisfied the
shortest answer I think is that our past
attitudes Institute norms that provide
the normative standards of assessment
for our current attitudes but such a
slogan conceals the rich fine structure
of his account he thinks that we
Institute norms that govern our
attitudes by engaging in a special kind
of process recollection his word is in
our own recollection retrospectively
rationally reconstructs the prior
applications of a concept picking out
expressively progressive trajectory
through them to say that the rationally
reconstructed tradition is expressively
progressive is to say that it takes the
form of the gradual emergence into
explicitness
of a determinant conceptual content
which provides a norm governing
applications of that
and that content is exhibited as having
been implicit all along each application
reveals some contour of the concept this
process of recollection adopts an
essentially retrospective perspective
the hell of Minerva flies only at dusk
it's this process the terms a mere
passed into a history something with the
edifying narrative structure of a
tradition a past comprehended he says
its reasons march through history this
idea of recollected rationality is one
of Hegel's big ideas in the rest of the
talk I want to drill down by looking at
a special case of that rec elective
reconciliation of traditional and modern
structures of norm governed and norm
instituting practices and the sort of
understanding of them that's enabled by
the meta concepts of hegelian furnished
the particular dimension of our guys
take activities that I'll address is
intentional agency and the self
conscious understanding of it of
theoretical and practical that is an
essential aspect of it
Hegel calls the traditional zitnick
practical understanding of intentional
agency heroic by this he means that
agents take responsibility for their
doings under all the descriptions that
are true of those doings no normative
distinction is made between what was
done intentionally or what the agent
knew he was doing on the one hand and
what he did unintentionally and without
realizing that that was what he was
doing on the other so Oedipus is held
responsible for killing his father and
marrying his mother even though he
didn't intend to do those things and was
not aware that that's what he's doing
for those who still thinks that he did
not things that just happened here we
might think of an scums slogan I do what
happens
Oedipus did intend to kill that man and
marry that woman on the traditional
heroic conception
it's the normative statuses that matter
not the agents attitudes parasite and
incest ought not to be
one should not hacked so as to incur the
normative status a father killer or
mother [ __ ] though ought to do is
governing attitudes are just to be read
off of the auto B's that articulates
statuses attitudes of knowing and
intending matter only in determining
that one is responsible for a deed not
for determining what one did thereby the
status one acquires by doing something
is not itself construed as mitigated by
or otherwise relativized in any way to
the attitudes of intending and knowing
in virtue of which it counts as one's
doing in the first place the one did not
mean to do what one did can engender
sympathy but does not in any way
diminish responsibility it's for this
reason Hegel thinks that the traditional
heroic practical conception of agency is
inevitably always also a tragic
conception the tragedy doesn't consist
in the transcendent awfulness of the
outcome which is pretty much what
current usage has whittled the concept
of tragedy down to it consists rather in
the fact that in acting at all when puts
oneself at the mercy who forces outside
of one's knowledge and control those
alien forces determine the content of
one's actual deed what when turns out to
have done and equivalently to be
responsible for having done Hegel quotes
in this connection a medieval European
proverb that says when a flung stone
leaves the hand it belongs to the devil
tragedy is the submission of the heroic
agent to fate and the idea of fate here
invokes not some sort of determinism or
antecedent necessitating of outcome but
just the presence of those dark because
unknowable and uncontrollable forces
that in engulf and overwhelm what is
launched by ones limited knowledge and
intention transforming it into deeds
that inevitably reach far beyond those
attitudes into an unforeseeable status
of culpability shouldering the
responsibility that fate in this sense
brings down upon one who acts is tragic
heroism
this is the intimate mutually
presupposing relation between
od fate and heroism that Hegel sees
structuring ancient Greek normativity by
contrast to this tragic practical
conception of agency in terms of heroic
identification with and submission to
one's fate the modern conception of
agency is distinguished precisely by the
idea that agents are genuinely
responsible for and so should be held
responsible for only what they intended
to do and knew they were doing Donald
Davidson
well articulates the distinction at the
core of the modern conception when he
distinguishes among the specifications
of things one is genuinely done between
descriptions under which one what one
did is intentional say turning on the
light and descriptions of what one did
that are merely consequential alerting
the burglar of whom one was unaware what
makes an event at doing at all something
that's imputable to an agent is that
it's intentional under some description
but that event then counts as a doing
under all its specifications including
those that pick it out by consequences
that were not intended or foreseen by
the agent it's of the essence of the
modern idea of practical responsibility
that acknowledgments and attributions of
the normative status of responsibility
are conditioned by and proportional to
the agents attitudes of intending and
believing it's now seen to be unjust to
condemn or blame someone for what they
did because it satisfies consequential
descriptions under which the agent did
not intend it and could not foresee it
those attitudes of agents what they
intend and believe are taken to play
constitutive roles in determining their
normative status as culpable or
admirable this conception of
responsibility is proportionate to
intention and knowledge is the
application to the practical
understanding of intentional agency of
the distinctively modern appreciation of
the attitude dependence of normative
statuses the core of distinctively
modern practical self-consciousness is
for Hegel a special way of understanding
what he calls the distinction that
action implies between what is purposed
and what is accomplished in the realm of
existence
it's to distinguish two senses in which
agents do things a narrower and a wider
one and a restrict responsibility to
what's done in the narrower sense here's
a long quote that's on your handout it's
the right of the will to recognizes its
action and to accept responsibility only
those aspects of the deed which it knew
to be presupposed within its end in
which were present in its purpose I can
be made accountable for a deed only if
my will was responsible for it that's
the right of knowledge he explicitly
appeals to this distinction as marking
the decisive difference from traditional
practical conceptions of agency another
quote the heroic self-consciousness has
in ancient tragedies like that of
Oedipus has not yet progressed for its
unalloyed simplicity to reflect on the
distinction between deed and action
between the external event and the
purpose and knowledge of the
circumstances or to analyze the
consequences minutely but accepts
responsibility for the deed in its
entirety Hegel takes it that making this
distinction between taught and Hahn long
the deed and the action is a decisive
advance in our understanding of
ourselves as agents but this new level
of practical self-consciousness kourt's
the danger of a distinctive kind of
alienation from its deeds he says
consciousness therefore through its
experience in which it should have found
its truth has really become a riddle to
itself the consequences of its deeds are
not four-hit the deeds themselves what
befall x' it is for it not the
experience of what it is in itself the
transition is not a mere alteration of
the form of the same content an essence
now presented as the content and again
as the object or outwardly beheld
essence of itself
I've been using a particular regimented
normative meta vocabulary to render the
terms that Hagel uses to set out the
contrast his contrast between categories
of fish dawned or understanding and
those are furnished or reason it
translates Hegel's talk of what subjects
are in themselves and what they are for
themselves and for others into talk of
normative statuses and normative
attitudes under the heading of normative
statuses Hegel's talk of independence
and dependence is translated into talk
about authority and responsibility and
under the heading of normative attitudes
his talk about what subjects are for
themselves and for others is translated
into talk about acknowledging
responsibility or claiming authority for
oneself and attributing those statuses
to others in these terms the meta
conception of fair known he recommends
and develops is what explains the
reciprocity of the normative statuses of
authority and responsibility the sense
in which there always for him two sides
of one coin it explains the reciprocity
of normative recog ativ attitudes of
acknowledging and attributing authority
and responsibility and it explains the
reciprocal dependence between those
reciprocal relations among statuses and
among attitudes in doing so it
reconciles the distinctively modern
insight into the attitude dependence of
normative statuses the sense in which
statuses of authority and
responsibilities are instituted by
reciprocal recog you to attitudes with
the traditional appreciation of the
Status dependence of normative attitudes
the dimension along which attributions
and acknowledgments of commitments
responsibilities undertaken by
exercising one's authority to do so
answer for their correctness to what
agents are really committed to the
alienation that is the worm in the shiny
Apple of modernity is the practical
incapacity to see how normative statuses
can both be instituted by normative
attitudes and transcend those attitudes
was genuinely to govern and constrain
them
Kant's autonomy version of the
Enlightenment idea that normative
statuses are instituted by normative
attitudes takes it that knowing and
acting subjects are distinguished from
merely natural creatures by a
distinctive sort of authority they have
that's the authority to commit
themselves the normative capacity of
making themselves responsible by taking
themselves to be responsible Hegel
applauds both the idea that the basic
normative status is the authority to
adopt normative attitudes for Kant
to acknowledge commitments and the idea
that normative statuses commitments that
his responsibilities are instituted by
normative attitudes Hegel objects though
to the idea that any individual's
attitudes can immediately constitute
normative statuses that sort of
authority he sees as an instance of the
practical conception of normativity in
terms of what he calls pure independence
Authority without commensurate
responsibility that's characteristic of
the master whose commands unilaterally
Institute obligations or
responsibilities for the slave in his
master slave allegory of traditional
normative structure of obedience and
subordination as such as such it's an
instance of that traditional practical
subordination obedient structural
understanding of normativity and from
Hegel's point of view it's a flaw in the
content autonomy account that this
foundational normative status the
distinctive kind of authority to commit
oneself in virtue of which one is a
discursive subject of cognitive
commitments as to how things are and
practical commitments as to how things
shall be is not construed by kant
as itself instituted by normative
attitudes it's just treated as a
metaphysical fact we have the authority
to commit ourselves Hegel's idea is that
we should understand the commitments of
normative subjects as instituted not by
their own attitudes of acknowledgment
alone as console autonomy model hazard
but only by those attitudes when
suitably comp
by attributions of those commitments to
them by others who attribute to them the
authorities so to commit themselves and
hold them responsible that is the
authority to commit oneself is itself
instituted in part by the attitudes of
others who attributed Kant's being
responsible for respecting the dignity
of others is being responsible for
attributing autonomy to them but he
didn't take that to be constitutive of
autonomy Hegel's term for the attitude
of attributing the basic Conte and
normative status that is the authority
to adopt a status by adopting an
attitude making oneself responsible by
taking oneself to be responsible is
recognition on Arcanum in place of
Kant's individualistic autonomy model of
the institution of normative statuses by
normative attitudes he proposes a social
recognition model according to that
model normative statuses are instituted
by reciprocal recognition to be
responsible one must as contador he
insisted in the first instance
acknowledged that responsibility at
least implicitly but one must also be
held responsible by others to whom one
attributes the authority to adopt such
authority of attitudes to attribute to
someone the authority to hold one
responsible that is to attribute
commitments in a partly constitutive way
is to recognize that other subject
migaila Enrico Beautif attitudes like
Conte and autonomous attitudes Institute
normative statuses but they do so only
when suitably socially complimented the
recognizance updates and of their
recognizance if Raqqah dependent that is
responsible to each other as well as
authoritative over each other on the
recognizance titude by normative
attitudes but only when those attitudes
exhibit a particular social structure
the structure structure of mutual
reciprocal recognition normative
attitudes of acknowledging oneself and
attributing responsibilities to others
and of claiming or exercising authority
for oneself and acknowledging the
authority of or attributing authority to
others must be complimentary to be
efficacious and in such a structure the
normative statuses of authority and
responsibility those recognizance
Institute are also always reciprocal and
coordinate one might think I think when
clearly ought to ought to think that
there is a sense of normative status
paradigmatically of responsibility and
authority that sensibly construed as
socially instituted by reciprocal recog
a t'v attitudes in the way required for
what I've called the basic Hegelian
normative statuses even so one might
might want to object-- that their
normative statuses that are more
objective than these either subjectively
constituted once what's left out of the
picture of normative statuses as
instituted by reciprocal recognizance
one wants to say is the fact that some
normative statuses are objective in a
sense that lets them serve as normative
standards for assessment of the
correctness of attitudes of attributing
or claiming them just so the attitude
dependence of normative statuses which
motivates the models both of the basic
Contin normative meta status of autonomy
and of the basic Hegelian normative meta
status of reciprocal recognition must
somehow be balanced by acknowledgement
of the status dependence of normative
attitudes the sense in which the
attitudes of acknowledging and
attributing normative statuses are
responsible to the statuses that
subjects actually have the sense in
which those attitudes are themselves
norm governed understanding that aspect
of the relations between normative
attitudes and normative statuses and
incorporating that understanding in our
practices and institutions is what's
required to move Geist from its modern
to it's postmodern phase we're to do
that by moving from practically
construing ourselves and our discursive
activities according to meta concepts
exhibiting the structure of fish dawned
- construing ourselves in our discursive
activities according to meta concept
exhibiting the structure of fair none
the key to the way the key to
understanding the way Hegel moves beyond
the basic Hegelian normative statuses
socially instituted by synchronic
reciprocal relations of recog eight of
attitudes consists in appreciating the
orthogonal diachronic historical
dimension of recog ativ processes his
social story has to be complemented by
his historical story it is in particular
the recollected phase of diachronic
recognizance ease that explains the
attitude transcendence of normative
statuses that includes the special
cognitive representational norms
according to which representing
attitudes are responsible for their
correctness two standards set by what
counts is represented by those
representing x' just in virtue of
exercising that distinctive kind of
authority over them discursive norms
both practical and cognitive are
understood according to the categories
of furnished
has features of essentially social and
historical record of processes
developing in tandem with attitudes that
articulate them understanding operating
according to the categories of fresh
dawned is blind to both the social and
the historical dimensions of conceptual
norms so I want now to look more closely
at how Hegel describes and motivates the
transition to the Third Age of Geist
which still lies ahead of us the spirit
chapter of the phenomenology rehearses
the progressive development from the
traditional to the modern structure of
Geist so as to prepare us readers for
the Epiphany in which that development
can culminates the envisage transition
to the third postmodern stage the age of
trust
Hegel introduces this newly
self-conscious form of normativity and
ends subjectivity in the rhetorical form
of a pair of allegories the allegory of
the hero and his valet and the allegory
of the penitent confessing his transit
transgression to the hard-hearted on
forgiving judge Hagel introduces the
first with a well known slogan of his
day no man is a hero to his valet
followed by his own twist on it not
however because the man is not a hero
but because the valet is of La the hero
is allegorical for one who acts out of
appreciation of his duty one who
fulfills his responsibilities when who
acts as he ought as he's committed to
act one who in his practical attitudes
and actions acknowledges the binding us
or authority of norms valet is the
english translation of the german comedy
nur literally room servant the valet in
the allegory sees the attitudes of the
hero not as governed by an expressions
of the acknowledgments of norms but it's
the product of immediate sensuous
desires and contingent particular
inclinations the valet views what the
hero does genealogically in resolutely
naturalistic non normative reductive
terms and so the quote on your handout
continues explains the action as
resulting from selfish motives just as
every action is capable of being looked
at from the point of view of conformity
to duty so - it can be considered
considered from the point of view of the
particularity of the doer
if the action is accompanied by Fame
then it knows this inner aspect to be a
desire for fame the inner aspect is
judged to be an urge to secure his own
happiness even though this were to
consist merely in an inner moral conceit
in the enjoyment of being conscious of
his own superiority and in the foretaste
of a hope of future happiness no action
can escape such judgment for duty for
duties sake this pure purpose is an
unreality it becomes a reality in the
deed of an individuality and the action
is thereby charged with the aspect of
particularity end of the quote the
camera Gaynor stands for a view that
explains all attitudes in terms of other
attitudes without needing to appeal to
the governing norms or statuses that
their attitudes towards and
acknowledgments of Hegel doesn't deny
that this sort of explanation in terms
of attitudes alone can be done the norm
blind reductive naturalist perspective
is an available though one-sided
perspective but we can ask what sort of
disagreement is it that divides the
camera dinner and the friend of the
norms for whom some heroes really are
heroes
is it a cognitive matter of factual
disagreement about what there is in the
objective world after all for Hegel
modernity was just right the normative
statuses are attitude dependent but
Hegel diagnoses the issue rather as a
difference in meta attitude he
denominates
the norm blind reductive naturalism of
attitudes for which the camera döner
stands as needed tactic the contrasting
norms sensitive status aware hero
acknowledging that attitude that takes
some attitudes to be themselves
genuinely norm sensitive and norm
acknowledging equals a diluting so
needed hike take is something like
literally pulling down and Adelman take
as magnanimous so perhaps there's just a
subjective practical choice to be made
depending on one's preference for tough
minded skeptical needed hike to kite or
tender minded generous a diluted kite
but that isn't Hegel's view either those
two possibilities matter of objective
fact or subjective preference exhaust
the possibilities that modern fresh
dawned admits but he thinks rather than
in being discursive beings at all in
believing and acting
we've already implicitly committed
ourselves to an a diluting meta attitude
this is a possibility
afforded by pronunced which when it
comes to explicit self-consciousness
pushers in the postmodern structure of
Geist
the issue addressed by the allegory of
the camera diner concerns the
intelligibility of the traditional idea
of the stateís dependence of normative
attitudes in the face of the modern
insight into the attitude dependence of
normative statuses the camera diner
stands for the self-sufficiency the
explanatory sovereignty of attitudes
but then what room is there for the
authority and efficacy of norms for the
idea that normative statuses of
authority and responsibility what one is
really entitled are committed to make a
real difference to attitudes that
accordingly deserve to be thought of as
acknowledgments of those norms normative
governance of attitudes by norms or
statuses has two dimensions chaotic and
a leathe ik first the norms the
normative statuses service standards for
assessment of the correctness of
attitudes my attitudes of acknowledging
a commitment myself or attributing a
commitment to others are correct just in
case we really are committed in case
those attitudes properly reflect the
statuses those attitudes are attitudes
towards this is what it is for the
attitudes in question to be normative
attitudes attitudes towards norms
attitudes of acknowledging or
attributing normative statuses but
second the norms their attitudes towards
should make a difference to the adoption
of those attitudes the attitudes must be
subjunctive ly sensitive to the
normative statuses they acknowledge and
attribute and this is to say that the
norms are efficacious in that if the
content of the norm being acknowledged
or attributed were or had been different
then the attitude would be or would have
been different the heroism of the hero
is allegorical for the norm governance
of his attitudes in this dual sense the
correctness of his attitudes is to be
assessed according to the standard
provided by the norms he acknowledges
and his practical attitudes are
sensitive to the contents of those norms
in the sense that if the norms were
different the hero's attitudes would be
different the challenge allegorically
represented by the camera diner is to
make the possibility of the status
dependence of normative attitudes so
much as intelligible in the face of the
standing possibility which Hegel admits
of purely naturalistic genealogical
alternative accounts of the advent of
normative attitudes which appeal only to
other attitudes if invocation of
normative governance of attitudes by
normative statuses is not necessary to
account for
attitudes how can it be legitimate
insofar as the reductive naturalist
challenge to the normativity of agency
cannot be met convincingly the result is
alienation from those norms the loss of
traditional zip the practical
appreciation of the Status dependence of
normative attitudes of the authority or
binding us of norms on attitudes the
second allegory of the confessing
miscreant and the hard-hearted judge
presents a different sort of challenge
to the intelligibility of the governance
of practical attitudes by norms it stems
from contine rigor ism about what's
required for genuine responsiveness to
norms rather than from reductive
naturalism what the miscreant confesses
is the admixture of non normative
attitudes in the causes of his action he
didn't just act out of an acknowledgment
of pure duty for duties sake other
attitudes also provided motives to which
the action was subjunctive ly sensitive
in a sense that if they had been
different in the norm not what was done
would have been different that's what
the genealogical storyteller tells us
about subjunctive sensitivity was not
limited to the content of the norm being
acknowledged the doing was in this
regard both more and less than a pure
acknowledgment of the norm here the
challenge is not the treating the
performances the acknowledgement of a
norm is not necessary to explain the
practical attitude but rather that it's
not sufficient if invocation of
normative governance is not play itself
sufficient to account for the attitudes
because of an admixture of contingent
particular motives and circumstances
what the penitent confesses then how can
it be legitimate the challenge to the
intelligibility of normative governance
comes from the idea that the authority
of norms over attitudes must be total in
order to be genuine it's a manifestation
of the deform conception of pure
independence the idea that authority
Hegel's normative independence is
undercut by any sort of correlative
responsibility to dependence on anything
else this is the practical normative
conception that Hegel criticizes
allegorically under the rubric of
mastery and slavery Hegel sees canta is
perfectly distilling the essence of the
modern form of this conception as part
of his otherwise progressive
understanding of normativity in terms of
autonomy as a result Kant adopts a
contraction strategy in which genuine
doing shrink down to mere willings since
every more robust sense of action
involves responsibility to other factors
subjective and objective which are not
themselves in the same sense governed by
the norm that rationalizes the willing
in the allegory the hard-hearted judge
is the contine rigorous who takes it
that the penitence confession of an
admixture of non normative motives shows
that the action does not also Express
the acknowledgment of a norm and so must
be judged lawless the affinity to
reductive naturalism of the camera
diners should be clear for their to the
mere possibility of a non normative
reductive naturalistic explanation of
attitudes is taken to preempt the
normative governance explanation and in
that sense to deny the authority of the
norm
if the normative governance account of
an attitude has a rival it's taken to
have no authority at all independence is
seen as incompatible with any sort of
dependence any correlative
responsibility undermines claims of
authority
unlike the camera döner allegory the
allegory of the hard-hearted judge is
extended to provide a path forward to a
proper understanding of the status
dependence of normative attitudes Hegel
presents the structural transition from
modern to postmodern conceptions of
agency in the form of a parable a
narrative recounting sequential stages
in the relationship between an evil
consciousness and a hard-hearted judge
judgment confession a refusal of
reciprocal confession the breaking of
the heart heart and the confession of
the judge forgiveness and the
achievement of a new kind of community
quote the reconciling yay in which the
two eyes let go their antithetical
existence is the existence of the eye
which is expanded into a duality this is
the final Phenom fatigue postmodern
conception of reciprocal recognition and
so of normativity in Geist structured by
normativity instituted by that newly
self-conscious form of recognition what
the contrite agent confesses is
everything in the deed that's not
Normand in Hegel's idiom every
manifestation of particularity the agent
circumstances and collateral attitudes
and the form of intentions are beliefs
and of contingent unintended
consequences rather than universality in
Hegel's term Pagels term for the norm
the governing normative status it
confesses every failure of the status
dependence of practical attitudes whose
content is revealed in the deed has
actually done confession in this sense
is that once a performance partly
constitutive of a special form of
self-consciousness and a petition for
recognition the connection is forged by
Hegel's understanding of
self-consciousness as a normative status
that's the social product of attitudes
of mutual recognition in Hegel's
allegory the confession is not met with
an a diluting reciprocating recognition
but with an eater tasting merely
critical assessment of failure to
fulfill responsibilities failure of
attitudes to be normatively governed by
statuses the blaming hard-hearted Conte
and rigorous judge plays Hegel says the
role of the moral valet to the penitent
agent quote the consciousness that
judges in this way is itself base needed
hating because it divides up the action
producing and holding fast to the
disparity of the action with itself
further it's hypocrisy because it passes
off such a judging not as another manner
of being wicked but it's the correct
consciousness of the action setting
itself up in this unreality and conceit
of knowing well and better above the
deeds at discredits and wanting its
words without deeds to be taken for us
kind of reality end of the quote the
judges attitudes are exclusively adopted
from the perspective of normative
assessment the judges Assessor does not
identify with the perspective of the
deliberating agent or even acknowledge
the essential complementary roles in
constituting normative statuses played
by attitudes of assessment and
deliberation that is the crucial social
perspectival distinction of attitudes of
attribution to another and
acknowledgement oneself of practical
commitments the point of this episode in
the hella gory is to enforce the
contrast with the next step the breaking
of the hard heart describes the adoption
by the assessing consciousness of the
appropriate Adel mu take retrocognition
stew the petition for recognition that
is the penitence confession that
responds Hegel denominates forgiveness
to understand the structure of
normativity that gives Geist its
characteristic postmodern shape we have
to understand the constellation of
reciprocal recog attitudes that
Institute's that structure this is
recognition in the form of mutual
confession and forgiveness the structure
of trust as I read the allegory the
shift to forgiveness that is the
breaking of the judges heart heart is a
move from the judge merely attributing
responsibility for the agent's deed to
the judge practically acknowledging his
own responsibility for that date as such
it's an act of identification with the
doer by making oneself co responsible
for what was done the appropriate
response to confession of an incapacity
to produce deeds that are simply and
purely governed by norms is for the
judge to make a corresponding confession
to acknowledge I am as you are admitting
that the judge like the agent is also
doomed to act from a mixture of
attitudes that are acknowledgments of
governing norms and attitudes that are
not such acknowledgments its slogan is
we're all bozos on this bus the
responsibility the assessing
consciousness undertakes for what's done
is socially complimentary to the
response
ability the deliberating consciousness
undertakes for its act rather than
identical with it it has two dimensions
reparative and rec elective the
reparative responsibility is practically
to intervene in the still unfolding
consequences of the doing which provide
an ever-increasing stock of
consequential specifications of it the
deed is never done and part of the
generous polluting way of holding
someone responsible for what they do is
to acknowledge responsibility for
helping to make it turn out well one can
do that by practically contributing new
consequences thereby making true new
consequential specifications of the date
when everyone acknowledges a
responsibility to do that each doing by
a member of the community's constitutive
recognizance
the form of confession and forgiveness
is it doing by all the deed of each is
the deed of all here we can think of
Dumas Musketeers slogan all for one and
one for all
but what count as better consequences
the standards for such normative
assessments of consequences is set by
the other dimension the REC elective
dimension of forgiveness the reparative
responsibility to ameliorate the
consequences of the doing being forgiven
must be understood in terms of
recollection the aim is to make the
whole results from one's current action
thought of as a contribution to a
tradition more fully and successfully
recollect able than that tradition would
otherwise be so this constraint too is
defined in terms of recollection its the
norms of recollection that determine
what counts as better consequences and
to which contributing to such
consequences must be subjectively
subjunctive ly sensitive recognition in
the form of recollected forgiveness is
the key to understanding norm governess
in general for Hegel taking rec elective
responsibilities for another's doing is
practically acknowledging the obligation
to tell and endorse a certain kind of
retrospective story about that doing
this is the responsibility to rationally
reconstruct it
as norm governed the forgiving recollect
er must discern an implicit norm that
governs the development of the deed this
is an intention in the sense of a nobs
aid which stands to the consequentially
extended deed or taught as the agents
initial purposing or vores odds stands
to the hon look the action and the
narrow sense specified only under the
descriptions explicitly licensed ting
licensed by the purposing that initiated
the performance the intention as object
must be exhibited as norman normatively
governing the doing in the dual sense
both of serving as a normative standard
for assessment of the practical
attitudes it governs each specification
of the doing being thought of as an
acknowledgment of that norm and as being
the norm that those attitudes can be
seen to have been subjectively sensitive
to in the sense that had the Norn been
different so would the attitudes when
req electively discerns or imputes a
norm that's in the form of an intention
or object something that governs the
practical process by specifying what's
being striven for or aimed at saying
that goes beyond just saying that it
serves as a normative standard for
assessments of the success of practical
attitudes for that could be true without
entailing that anyone cares about the
standard and is making decisions in the
light of what the norm in joins the
additional element involves thinking of
each component of the subsequent
retrospectively constructed or
discovered tradition as surrounded by a
cloud of incompatible alternatives the
recollected forgiver then practically
takes or treats the subject of the
attitude in question as choosing the
alternative taken the one incorporated
in the recollect of recall you'd have
forgiveness narrative as having selected
it out of the cloud of relevant
alternatives which are sacrificed for it
that's what it is to treat the governing
norm is not just a normative assessment
but as an intention this is rationally
reconstructing a tradition of attitudes
that our state is dependent in the sense
of being governed in the dual sense by
an implicit norm that becomes gradually
more explicit as it's acknowledged by
the attitudes incorporated in the
recollected tradition the meta norm that
governs recollected performances and the
practical attitudes they express is that
the norm one reconstructive lis discerns
or imputes must normatively govern all
the consequential specifications of
attitudes downstream from the action and
the narrow sense that includes the
practical reparative and hermeneutic req
elective attitudes the assessing judge
adopts so the forgiving agent must
endorsed the norm being attributed as
governing the deed must acknowledge its
authority that's part of taking Co
responsibility for it
in forgiving one makes oneself
responsible for the emerging norm when
attributes is the implicit intention of
the deed this is identifying with the
agent in the sense of risking and if
need be sacrificing one's own attitudes
by subjecting them to normative
assessment according to the norm that
when both the tributes and acknowledges
and being subjectively sensitive to that
norm in one's own attitudes in this
specific sense the forgiving agent
acknowledges the doing as its own as the
doing not only of the agent who
initiated it but also of the forgiving
recollect er forgiving recollection can
be understood on the model of
institutional common or case law
jurisprudential practices the current
judge rationally reconstructs the
tradition by selecting a trajectory of
prior presidential decisions that are
expressively progressive in that they
reveal the gradual emergence into
explosiveness of a norm the content of a
law that can be seen to have implicitly
governed in the dual sense all the
decisions are attitudes in the
reconstructed tradition it's that norm
that then justifies the current judges
decision the norm that scene is emerging
from the rationally reconstructed
tradition of decisions sets the standard
for normative assessment by future
judges of the current decision which
claims to be subjunctive ly sensitive to
that very norm
so the recollecting judge subjects
herself to acknowledges the authority of
the nor
she retrospectively discerns the more of
the prior decisions the recollection
rationalizes and exhibits is expressive
of the norm
the better the reck elective warrant
that norm provides for the current
decision whatever residue there is of
decisions that cannot be fit into the
retrospective rationally reconstructed
tradition as presidentially
rationalizing an expressive of the norm
increases the scope for criticism of the
current decision by future judges who
may or may not acknowledge it is correct
and it's self presidential for the only
Authority the decision has derives from
its responsibilities to a tradition of
prior decisions forgiving wreck
electively recognizing on this account
is hard work it can't be brought off
with a single sweeping abstractly
general gesture I forgive you for what
you did one could always say that but
saying it wouldn't make it so besides
commitment to practically effect the
consequences of the doing one is
forgiving when was produce a concrete
recollect of reconstruction of the deed
under all its intentional and
consequential specifications
recollection is a kind of making the
crafting of a distinctive kind of
narrative that's successful only insofar
as it ends up being recognizable as
having the form of a finding that seems
a perverse description of a doing but
it's giving contingency the normative
form of necessity recollection is the
narrative genre in which the
rationalization of decisions appealing
to commoner case-law
belongs one must recruit and assemble
the raw materials one inherits so as to
exhibit a norm one can endorse oneself
as always having governed the tradition
to which one oneself belongs and with
which one oneself identifies a tradition
that shows up as progressively revealing
a governing norm making ever more
explicit what was all along implicit the
expressively progressive tradition
discerned culminates for now in the
consequential specification of the doing
that is the recollection itself well we
can ask what if what one's given to work
with is too hard to forgive in this
demanding sense what if the subject of
the attitude that's being forgiven is
part of the larger enterprise of
forgiving something upstream of it is in
fact disposition ly unresponsive to the
verdict of the norm what if as the
camera dinner alleges it is in fact
sensitive only to other attitudes and
concerns particular to its subject it
seems that the criteria of adequacy for
successful forgiveness both reparative
and wreck elective or in many cases
impossible to satisfy some things people
have done we want to say are simply
unforgivable the 20th century offers
plentiful candidates in some cases
though we might try to mitigate the
consequences of evil doings we just have
no idea how to go about discerning the
emergence of a governing norm we could
endorse ourselves and this situation
doesn't just arise in extraordinary
cases any actual recollected story will
involve strains elements of what's
actually done at every stage in the
developing process that cannot be
smoothly successfully or convincingly
given such norm responsive explanation
indeed but now we must ask whose fault
is it that the doing is unforgivable the
doer or the forgiver is the failure that
of the bad agent or of the bad rare
collector is it a matter of how things
anyway just are given what was done
considered as a settled fact or is it
because the rector couldn't come up with
a more normative narrative the first is
the attitude of the unzipping camera
diner for whom no one is practically
norm an practically norm acknowledging
ero
in a sense of being genuinely responsive
and sensitive to norms to treat the
recollected failure is wholly the fault
of the doer to take it as simply an
objective fact that there's no norm we
could endorse that governs the deed is
the Assessor inherits it is to adopt
exactly the blaming practical attitude
of the hard-hearted judge an attitude
Hegel criticizes as need attracting the
contrasting a diluting attitude
Rek electively he recollected Li
recommends as implicit in the idea of
norm governess as such is rather to
identify with the doer to take Co
responsibility for the doing that is to
acknowledge at least equal
responsibility on the part of the
unsuccessful forgiver for the issue is
not properly posed inally thick modal
terms of the possibility or
impossibility of forgiving what was done
it's rather a deontic normative matter
one is committed to forgiving
responsible for forgiving we have here a
gaily inversion of a Conte and
regulative ideal the governing
regulative ideal is to compound let's
say to palden a one can be committed to
that ideal normatively governed by it in
the dual sense even if one must confess
that in many cases one cannot understand
and so forgive all it might well be that
what is in fact incapable of fulfilling
that commitment of carrying out that
responsibility if and insofar is that so
it's a normative failure that the
unsuccessful would be forgiver should
confess to take proper req we're
cognizant to confess her own inadequacy
to the req elective task your confession
of a failure of your practical attitudes
appropriately to acknowledge a norm is a
petition from my recognition in the form
of my forgiving taking Co responsibility
for your doing my subsequent failure to
adopt adequately forgiving req elective
recognizance is something I'm in turn
responsible for confessing that
confession is itself an act of
identification with you I am as you are
my attitudes like yours fail adequately
to satisfy the norms they nonetheless
acknowledge as binding as governing
those attitudes for one acknowledges an
obligation the binding of a governing
norm insofar as one confesses the extent
to which one has been unresponsive to
the demands of the req elective norm
unable properly to fulfill a
responsibility one acknowledges and one
is genuinely sensitive to that norm
of demand in making such a confession so
confessing is what one must do to make
it the case that that one is in fact
sensitive to the norm recollected as
governing the attitudes that make up the
tradition one has discerned including
one's own attitudes even though one is
incapable fulfilling the
responsibilities when thereby
acknowledges as an idle mooting
magnanimous forgiving Assessor of
another's doing when confesses that it's
also one's own fault that one is not
good enough at forgiving and one must
trust that this failure to like the
failure of the original inadequately
forgiving doer will be more successfully
forgiven by future Assessors who know
more and are better at it the one cannot
successfully tell a recollected story is
not what matters that's a day on tech
failure relative to one's commitments
it's something to be confessed in trust
that that failure too can be forgiven
the well-meaning but incompetent
forgiving recollect errs confession like
that of the contrite agent is a petition
for recognition in the form of
forgiveness the trusting confession of
recollected failure completes the
identification of the one playing the
role of the Assessor with the one
playing the role of the deliberating
agent the recognizance ession emerges
two sides of one coin two aspects of the
symmetric recognizance titute instructor
of trust its slogan is attribute
responsibility forgivingly acknowledged
responsibility contritely in a normative
community with this recognizance truck
sure everyone forgives to the limits of
their ability and everyone confesses
those limits and trusts that they too
will be forgiven from them from each
according to his abilities to each
according to his needs the content of
the shared were cognitive attitudes with
which all identify is forgive us our
trespasses as we forgive those who
trespass before us it's of the essence
of both the reparative reparative
ameliorating dimension and the
hermeneutic req elective dimension of
the recognizance
dresses that expresses a prior practical
attitude the doing being forgiven must
already be underway and for this reason
the final frenetic form of reciprocal
recognition as confession and
forgiveness is essentially historical
the attitude governing norms at
Institutes and acknowledges have the
rich diachronic
recognizance structure of traditions
Hegel practices forgiving recollection
retrospectively rationally
reconstructing expressively progressive
traditions in his own accounts of
intellectual and cultural history and in
the way he reads the histories of art
religion and especially philosophy it's
what I mean to be practicing and telling
this story the claim that's crucial for
understanding the Third Age of Geist is
retaining the progress made by modernity
while overcoming its structural
alienation is that recognition
understood is including the req elective
institution of traditions acknowledges
both the attitude in the attitude
dependence of normative statuses and the
Status dependence of normative attitudes
on the one hand it incorporates the
insight that norms normative statuses
are instituted by reciprocal recognition
that is by recog 'native attitudes that
are symmetric in a sense of being
suitably complimented on the other hand
each req electively rational
reconstruction is obliged to display the
normative attitudes it addresses as
governed by norms by normative statuses
in the dual sense of being subject to
assessment according to those norms and
being subjectively sensitive to them in
this way the postmodern recog ativ
practice reiative as if ik appreciation
of the authority of norms over attitudes
the sense in which attitudes are
responsible to governed by norms that
they acknowledge and attribute as
genuinely binding it's true that
acknowledgement of the authority of
governing norms is always within the
scope of a req elective rational
reconstructive story about what's going
on the normative status on which
attitudes are understood as dependent to
which they're responsible is itself
always the object of a req elective
attitude in this sense the overall
account invokes
nothing but attitudes but that status is
ER state is dependent that is norm
governed is an essential necessary and
characteristic structural feature of
every req elective attitude as such and
in that sense the Status dependence of
normative attitudes
is not merely a contingent product of
some attitudes people happen to adopt it
is in the end what makes normative
attitudes normative attitudes
acknowledgments and attributions
distinguished by their social
perspectives of normative statuses of
responsibility and authority agency in
the age of trust RIA Jeeves the heroic
character so striking in the original
ancient form of agency that was pushed
out by the ironic distancing and
alienation from norms essential to the
achievement of individuals
self-consciousness that is the triumph
of modern over traditional forms of
normative life central to heroism was
what Hegel called character the decisive
zitnick identification of an individual
agent with the norms practically
treating them as authoritative over and
binding on one's attitudes this is an
acknowledgement of the status dependence
of normative attitudes of one's
attitudes is norm governed the ought to
do governing normative attitudes
acknowledged or attributed
responsibilities are understood is
wholly determined by the ought to B's
that articulate normative statuses what
someone's really responsible for or
committed to their duty as a result the
heroic agent takes responsibility for
every aspect of his act if some feature
of it is not as it ought to be that is
confessed to be the agents
responsibility whether or not it was
intended or foreseen compared to the
contracted modern conception the heroic
conception makes the agent primarily
responsible for a much expanded date
stretching out to include distant
unanticipated consequences this was the
reason the traditional heroism was
essentially tragic
it requires subjecting oneself to dark
the dark unknowable power of fate
identifying with what one is made by
forces beyond one's knowledge and
control shouldering the responsibility
that fate in this sense brings down on
one who
his tragic heroism and heroism in the
age of trust is like heroism in the age
of tragedy and it's it the
acknowledgment of the binding us of
norms in the sense of their governing
authority over normative attitudes the
Status dependence of those attitudes
there are norms that set standards for
assessment of the correctness of our
attitudes of acknowledging and
attributing responsibility and authority
and it is the responsibility of each
agent to be sensitive to those norms
shaping our attitudes accordingly
each forgiving retrospective req
elective rational reconstruction of an
expressively progressive tradition of
attitudes is responsible for discerning
just such governing norms and where the
Crampton contracted modern practical
conception of agency to a bright line
between normatively attributable and
assessable aspects of each doing and non
normative ones between what the agent
can properly be held responsible for
because done knowingly or intentionally
and what's done only in the sense of
happening because of such doings in a
narrow sense the trusting conception is
heroic like the tragic conception in
that responsibility is total
responsibilities taken for the whole
deed
there's no aspect of intentional doings
that overflows and falls outside the
normative realm of responsibility no
specification of the deed for which no
one takes responsibility in Geist with
the recognizance truck sure of trust
responsibility for the deed is shared
between the agent whose practical
attitudes initiated the doing and the
members of her Rakata community who take
it as their own by committing themselves
to forgiving it agency is understood and
practiced within the magnanimous for
cognitive structure of confession and
forgiveness combines these two heroic
aspects of the pre-modern conception one
the zitnick appreciation of the Status
dependence of normative attitudes and
acknowledging total responsibility for
the date as consequentially extending
beyond the knowledge and control of the
agent it can maintain a heroic expanded
conception of the deed for which
responsibility is taken because it has
an expanded conception of who's
responsible for each
doing complementary recognizance titute
the governing norms and acknowledged the
authority of the norms so instituted the
essentially historical fine structure of
these reciprocally related recognizance
of statuses articulates a social
division of normative labor between the
agent whose practical attitudes initiate
a self conscious intentional doing who
takes responsibility for it in one sense
and members of the agents were
cognitively who take responsibility for
it in another sense in this way the two
essentially modern insights into the
attitude dependence of normative
statuses and the distinction of
responsibilities marked by the
individual agents rights of intention
and knowledge are respected and
synthesized with the two principal
features of pre-modern heroic agency but
the fair non fatigue trusting conception
of agency as heroic does away with the
element of tragic subjection to fade
fate showed up as an alien in human
force in the tragic form of agency
because was a non normative force one
that although not itself governed by
norms nevertheless substantially shapes
our normative responsibilities what was
left to us was bearing up and carrying
on in the face of the results of
incursions by alien fate into the
properly normative realm in which we
dwell the Neo heroic form of practical
normativity replaces fate something that
happens with something that we do what
happens is given the form of something
done immediacy contingency particularity
and there recall Citron's to
conceptualization are not done away with
but they now take their proper place for
we appreciate the necessary role they
play in the process of determining the
contents of the norms we both Institute
by our recognizance P 'real
the burdens of tragic subjection to fate
are replaced by the tasks of concrete
magnanimous forgiveness where our
normative conceptual digestion and
domestication of immediacy contingency
and particularity shows its limitations
when as in each case as the camera Deena
reminds us at some point they must they
outrun our rec elective capacity to
incorporate them into the mediated
normative conceptual form of governing
universals that failure of ours is
properly acknowledged by confession and
Trust in the forgiveness of that failure
to fulfill our responsibilities by not
more knowledgeable and capable future
will recollect errs one of the last
passages in the phenomenology the wounds
of the Spirit heal and leave no scars
behind the deed is not imperishable it's
taken back by spirit into itself and the
aspect of individuality present in it
whether as an intention or an existent
negativity and limitation straightway
vanishes the self that carries out the
action the form of its act is only a
moment of the whole and so likely and so
likewise is the knowledge that by its
judgment determines and establishes the
distinction between the individual and
the universal aspects of action and to
the quote the responsibility that the
individual tragic heroic agent takes on
himself is accordingly in the modern
form spread out and shared the doing of
each in one sense is now in a real sense
than doing of all in another record of
lis complimentary sense for all share
responsibility for and authority over
each action the distinctive essential
role played by individual agents is not
obliterated for the responsibility and
authority acknowledged by and attributed
to the initiating agent is different
from the reparative and rec elective
responsibilities and authority
acknowledged by those who take up the
burden of forgiving the agent every deed
now shows up both as a practical
contribution to the content of all that
came before it and is acknowledging a
recollected responsibility with respect
to all those deeds the temporally
extended historically structured
recognizance Essex tent of their
failures to be norm governed
acknowledging their responsibility to
forgive those failure and failures and
others confessing the ways in which
their efforts
a trek elective and reparative
forgiveness fell short of their goal and
trusting that a way will be found to
forgive their failures is one in which
each member identifies with all the
others taking responsibility for their
practical attitudes it is what Hegel
calls the I that is way and the we that
is high
[Applause]
yes I have a question about sort of like
say the roman genocide advantage I guess
I wonder what we've heard yet because we
know more we're better at it but we're
really remote from you don't kill a
special ship to them when I think of so
many 2000 years forgetting about the
20th century I want to say who are today
to do it and maybe it's too easy for
them they're pretty good not because
they're better at seeing the grand plan
but because they're so very remote for
all that happened it's just completely
drive down so I see when you're 30
yeah I'm you're describing difficulties
of confession and and maybe confessing a
failure to identify with the ones who
with the Romans who you know created a
particular massacre that that is that
they aren't members of your recognizance
Oh far as you say look this was just so
so long ago and far off that it's it has
nothing to do with me I didn't attribute
to Hegel the claim that we're better at
it and no more that was all in the scope
of we trust that those who come after us
you know we'll be able to do what we
couldn't do maybe because they are
better at it and no more that's you know
a normative stance that we take you're
giving reasons to think yeah well it may
get more more and more difficult rather
than less and less difficult as times go
on I think you know that that very well
might be matter of factually true it
isn't going to change the nature of the
obligation that Hegel sees this isn't
acknowledging here yes
is the Christian theological terms
ecology and even the account of the
hard-hearted judge is very much Hegel's
sort of coded language for speaking
about Jewish ethics - in the spirit of
Christianity and it's baby explicitly
those are both transcend
yeah I mean I I think yes and no he
means to be doing here I think what
Conte does in religion within the bounds
of reason alone that is reading
Christian theology as an allegory for
fundamental facts about the structure of
normativity in particular fundamental
facts about the structure of modern
normativity rather than the ancient
tradition whether he's so he's
explicitly using the the Christian
language the language of the time that
he's trying to capture in Florida in the
philosophy of right his picture of
modernity there he's not looking to the
next stage that he clearly thinks if
you've got a nation-state if you've got
representative political institutions if
you have a market economy bourgeois
family and Protestant Christianity
you've really got modernity you know you
are maybe there's some rough edges that
need to be more and off but that really
is the essence that modernity is aiming
for as I say there he doesn't seem to be
sort of pointing beyond it
and I think it's with that picture that
in mind that he's trying to read the
allegory of what the Protestant
Christianity that language what deeper
truths that was really telling us I mean
if you take it just as Christian
theologies very
Christian but by the time you've allowed
him to read these allegories but he does
need to be telling us there is something
true about what they said he is
recollected ly forgiving that language
which from his point of view read non
allegorically incorporates a literally
unbelievable metaphysics of morals
indeed a pre-modern a pre-modern one but
which went through a transformation and
came to be a language available for
moderns he's telling us how that
language can be available for
postmoderns I interpreted his reading of
the allegory
allegorically and used his language I
don't think you could say all of these
things without picking confession and
forgiveness indeed because I use those
terms because those are the terms he
uses but the language of neither tasting
chitin a diluting type for instance that
has a lot more to do with sort of
ancient Greek pictures of magnanimity
and pusillanimous a that it does with
any particular Christian picture so I
think the scheme ends up swinging free
of the allegory of Christian theology
that uses to convey it but insofar as it
doesn't insofar as his forgiveness of
his recollected forgiveness of that
language didn't take him far enough away
from it well then that's a task for us
sorry in a way that sweeps freer of that
language
it would be a recollected forgiving
version of his story or make the making
that is successful only insofar as it
has the shape of a fine day
has attracted to think that we should
strive to forgive everything that seems
objectionable to me or to reasons I want
to normalize attracted so what is fun
that you mentioned but in the following
way there are just some things that are
not forgivable where I don't take that
to be shorthand for I'm not up to the
task I take that to me there are some
things that we should forgive it
- and there's a second baby which is it
seems - this is a strange way to put it
but it seems to put into that morning
surgery strikingly different everything
these infants highline's people and to
not actually recognize them as capable
genuinely unforgivable jeez I feel like
some scene in the sitcom where somebody
does something random and then carefully
number to keep represents what you need
to say is it some positive light and
Kevin no no no is it possible you need
to say in some other positive light and
it's failing to get this is a person
here who doesn't want to be seen
necessarily under a positive that seems
to be a second it's family we take the
person seriously to insist on hearing
them as acting in conformity with some
norm that we've all along accepted but
maybe behind like will be realized
so so these do this I'm fine
active what am i busy well there's this
is a Pollyanna picture that that he has
this interesting unacceptable view that
this dead man has no eye I did I do
think it's it's an attractive you how
that there isn't and could not be an
objective fact of an axe so that was
intrinsically evil objectively so so
that it was not a matter of our matter
available to responsible to our
attitudes towards that that seems to me
remnant of a pre-modern way of thinking
changeable by our attitudes
I mean Hegel is a nice it's a
pollyannaish view he's in the line it's
a tradition everything's for the best in
best of all possible worlds in fact this
becomes a regulative ideal well that's
that's the way we should it becomes the
object of a commitment an obligation to
acknowledge a responsibility to make
that cell and this carefully crafted
crafted notion of recollected
rationality which he thinks of it has
reason it's March through history you
know the world we get is not rational as
it comes to us but if you look on the
world with rational artists the world
will look rationally back how do you do
that you do that by telling these REC
elective rationalizing stories and in
principle too bad and and wouldn't allow
the idea that he produced me an
objective fact that there were things
that were impenetrable is impenetrable
to that maybe there's a future of the
world that he's overlooking there but I
do find the the commitment that he's
summoning us to an attractive one I mean
you also ask whether this wasn't a view
that infantilized those who are
forgiving Hegel notoriously has a hard
to motivate
view of punishment as something the
community positively owes to a miscreant
the the miscreant has attempted to flee
the recognition community is trying not
to adopt practical attitudes of
recognizing other people's authority or
responsibilities and the community says
no we still recognize you you're still
one of us had argues that the punishment
is the form that recognition needs to
take that says no no you can't reject
world community with us now maybe that's
another intuitive or infantilizing sort
of view well why shouldn't he if he
wants to reject recognition with us in
the end well it's because you can talk
you can talk you are one of us we do
have this obligation to you again that's
a that universalizing is a kind of
it depends on what you mean by
punishment locking locking someone in a
cage can't be recognizing them as one of
us that's treating someone as an animal
rather than as one of us I mean what you
get is your reparative responsibility
well that's all right we've got to
mitigate the effects of what you did
but the recollected one too is
incorporating into a progressive
understanding of what we're all doing
and what the connection is between that
and traditional notions of punishment
that's not something I am sorry this is
sort of the background that together
with some other premises leads to that
way of thinking
and I think this leads to
Comparative restorative will a
reflective theory of maybe not
punishment but of forgiveness
so I back to your example Medicus
responsible for conceptions that is
responsible for actions that are
consequences are not intended by its
actions that's what makes it a tragic
hero so I guess I'm kind of wondering at
what would what would the public the
story different if it was this seems to
me that this is not think her is
punishment but he's one who desires and
he's the one that makes crayon now
transfer imperial power ventures prions
exile Island from the city so I'm
guessing it is me it seems like it's not
so much like a recognition that the
people around him rather that he himself
is holding up
it's not it's not because he's even
though technology is not his intention
father that nonsense that is all I think
indeed he himself completely buys into
the pre-modern conception and he has
done these things he is a parasite and
so he's responsible for that how that's
not something you can get out from under
whatever kinds of atonement you can
think that we're not going to undo that
but they might acknowledge that he is
this bad person because we killed his
father the claimant modernity is if you
find yourself with the best will in the
world trying to do something good doing
something that has a bad consequence
unless you look you aren't really
responsible if you could not have
foreseen this as a consequence of what
you did is not what you intended you
couldn't have foreseen it then you can
be sorry that this about the bad
sequelae from it but you would be wrong
to blame yourself for that you're not
responsible for it in any accept the
most attend ewis the most tenuous of
senses trying to teach you them to take
responsibility for
I mean we see more sophisticated
versions of this if Hagel sees in not
the Oedipus Antigone Sophocles play the
first sort of bubbling not both
modernity and it's very sorry bubbling
as I thought of it and it's in this
particular one Aquinas this doctrine of
double effect is making a distinction
that Hegel himself as far as I could see
doesn't make between what he calls the
right of attention in the right of
knowledge saying look if we consider two
cases where you do the bad thing in both
of them but one of them that's why you
did it you wanted to do the bad thing
that was content of your intention and
the other the content of your intention
was not doing the bad thing but you knew
that if you did what you were gonna do
with the bad thing would be a result and
the quite as well in the second case
you're not as culpable as you are in the
first case where the Vidhan thing was
part of the intention part of the reason
for which you did it the basis of the
best case restate literature but but
it's absolutely an expression of this
sense of modernity that April's
articulated for us to make distinctions
of culpability based on knowledge and
intention
and you know we would see pre-modern
remnants you know if you're the mafia
bodyguard and your principal gets killed
then you get killed doesn't matter
whether there was anything that would
have done about it your responsibility
was to protect him and if you didn't do
that then off with your head
well that's a remnant of this pre-modern
pre-modern sense
bloodthirsty sense of whether whether
what you did was was the party line
and you say the type of solid well at
the time I did it this was the party
line look at the newspaper there yes but
it isn't the party law in math and it
doesn't matter that you were doing what
you thought was the party line because
that was what everyone was saying well
if it's not in accord with the party
line
now then you're responsible for it that
that's a remnant type of pre-modern
notion responsibility so Oedipus himself
didn't have this thought available to
him so he took responsibility heroically
for all these descriptions
responsible forgiveness isn't really in
the picture at all I mean he can feel
bad that this thing happened to him that
it turned out that he's this bad person
that he is the parasite and if a tenant
is appropriate for that okay but it's
likely it's not going to undo it at all
it's just his acknowledgment yes it's
not that I think being a parasite is a
good thing now I'm terrible so I'm not
seeing any remnant any bit of modern
sensibility in that innocent
I understand certain actions but for
what I understand the gradually
construction involves giving a certain
read ascription to what was deemed bad
in the first place so my person is under
the new description of what the
intention of the agent was due he gets a
certain a certain opposition between
that's norm that in some sense we
understand this part of our community
and the original norm that judged the
reconstructed
because it seems hard for me to see how
we could get that case both forms as
ours
it would seem that we no longer
recognize the faults in the original
intention so I assume that in this
possibly construction also reconstruct
the original form or appeal to some
higher standard I mean it's about the
matter to talk about the original form a
fruit on this rationale across
structures think that in the cases of
the judges at common law so at one point
we're looking back and we need to decide
whether this is a case of strict
liability in a civil court and so we've
got these cases boulders to go on as
well in this set of facts is decided
that the individual was strictly liable
in this other cases decided that it
wasn't now we've got a new set of facts
the only rationale we can give for
making decision one way or another is to
invoke the authority of these previous
decisions and so we do that we tell a
story well these are the respects of
similarity and dissimilarity these are
the important ones and these are the
cases that were presidential that I'm
treating is really having authority to
determine what the law is that's on
display here we see well what about
these other cases if if you're right in
the current judge giving this rationale
not only are you not treating that case
as presidential but you're treating it
as mistaken but by the rule that you're
extracting from this that decision was
wrongly decided yes that's according to
me
you know what I'm seeing the norm that I
see as being expressed in these
decisions
some of these earlier decisions they
were just long but maybe a judge who
comes on after me we get a new set of
new set of facts decisions make this
ain't no no I'm the one who miss applied
the law or something I didn't understand
about the norm whose boundaries are
getting more and more clear and actually
the one that I took to be wrongly
decided that was correctly decided and
his precedent it was exhibiting a
contour of the emerging norm that I when
I made my decision about it it was
simply trying to do that sort of
re-evaluation sort of at every stage
though the law courts trying to minimize
that sort of thing happens all the time
and that's a model an instance of the
sort of thing that I'm attributing that
I've attributed to end that we're to
treat those actions and practical
attitudes that are not in accord with
the norm that governs them in the sense
of being the standard for assessment of
correctness or incorrectness for them
according to this national
reconstruction of that
to see that as a call to a college a
commitment to find a better story that
will incorporate these two has in accord
with the now reconstructed norm
acknowledging that we're never going to
get everything in that's what we have to
confess but acknowledging also the
commitment to do what we can
so I only have seen that this is wrong
oh okay I mean I see it a certain point
of contact with Shelly's worried that
you're going to be undercutting the
distinction between what is in accord
with the norm of what is not in accord
with the norm if whenever you make the
decisions okay that's not an accord with
it this is you had that little asterisk
on it but in a better story this would
be in accord with it yeah he's giving a
radical new semantics a new theory of
the content of norms today that's my
principal interest is in the semantics
the semantics story that says we're
accustomed to thinking about the
contents of these dorms as though they
were so crystal and things that were
there that that drew lines
like this in fact contents are these the
contents of conceptual norms are these
protein growing things that we can we
have to understand in terms of a
retrospective perspective on them every
time we look back we do make a
distinction between correct and
incorrect applications and looking
forward where we're looking at the
process of well looking forward it looks
like we're changing the norms that we
inherit by making it by treating some as
presidential or others is not of the
jurisprudential slogan for the case law
and common law cos judge-made law
they're saying they're not interpreting
while they're making it up as they go
along and there's a sense of which
that's right because there is nothing to
it except what's been put into it by
these decisions and yet it's an
essential element that everybody is not
just arbitrarily deciding this or that
but the only Authority their decision
has is the extent to which they're
responsible to the to the things before
and so he's challenging us to think
about the contents of our own thoughts
and intentions as own not sort of having
their content all in the moment when you
have the belief or have the intention
but eating content for only as part of a
extended a thing that's extended in time
in which from one point of view isn't
changing it's just becoming more
explicit but from another point of view
all the deterrent of this is being put
into it by the attitudes of applying it
in one case and refusing to apply it
in another case and I think it is hard
to put our minds around thinking of the
contents of our own minds in that sort
of way
I find I personally find the self
reconstructive powers that Hegel
attributed to reason to be attractive
indeed but my thing is how you get from
that to the retrieval of the perova
condition which included because it
seems at least on face value that
heroism consists in the accomplishment
that an exceptional be forgiven for
failure but I understand but I'm saying
how heroism in the classic sense is
bearing up under the fact that so
accepting the fact that everything you
do get significance is outside of your
control and nonetheless accepting
responsibility for all those things that
that's the heroic that's what 0ik is not
sort of begging off and saying oh but I
didn't know yes that can as I say their
genders sympathy but the hero has to say
but but that's who I am and had to
realize that what you are is not
entirely up to you risk depends on faith
you throw the stone which might kill
someone
and now you
murderer or missing entirely and no harm
no foul don't say to someone you can
well I didn't mean to
or even in that case you know didn't
know that that even might happen that
that's the original heroism is taking
responsibility for the doing under all
of these descriptions have a claim was
that in the his picture of the
postmodern age of trust there at least
won't be a distinction between aspects
of the deed that fall outside the
normative route no no one is responsible
for them even though it's a feature of
the doing it's just you need to expand
the notion of the agent in that regard
beyond the context of deliberation to
the context of assessment where the
where the judge sort of lives looking on
of it and see the significance of what's
done is the product of their ricotta
negotiation ISM this process
[Applause]
[Music]